you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with
petees what's happening weirdos this is
Malik alisol who I recorded with several
months ago but I've been working with
he's been opening for me from time to
time I met him in uh Montreal and I was
blown away he is so funny you may not
know who he is but you will and this is
you finding out about him in fact right
up top here I want to play a clip I
believe this is from The Moth this is a
clip of Malik being super super
hilarious so you can have a little taste
of who he is and how great he is before
we get into our conversation so Katie
roll that clip I am looking for Peace of
Mind man I've been I've been I've been
going to a therapist for for 4 years I
think it's a
scam at least I don't have a good
therapist like I cuz I didn't like get
referred like by a doctor like I just
like went online like I just like
Googled help please please
help and then it took me to a website
and on the website it was like write out
a list of your problems so we can use
that to like match you up and I was like
all right and I selected anxiety because
that's what I was that's what I was
having and then it was like write out
the anxiety explain what that feels like
so that we can use that to better match
you up to somebody and I was like it's
anxiety it's not going to make sense I
was like
okay I'm not as good of a Muslim as I
was raised to be but I still feel like a
good person you know and it's I feel
conflicted cuz in school they taught us
that everything is written before we're
even born like all my decisions are made
for me so it's like am I just doomed to
make these mistakes that God wrote for
me like like what if Allah judges me
unfairly and then I submitted that
and then they were like you should talk
to Helen about this Helen Helen's good
for [__] like this she's she's on top of
it trust me and I was like Helen are you
even listening to what what is Helen
going to do you couldn't have brought me
like a Dr Mahmud El shabaz somebody to
just tell me to pray brother your life
is Haram of course you feel
terrible at least he
understands what's I'm going to be in a
meeting with Helen she's going to be
like tell me more about this Allah
character
he sounds toxic I I mean why would you
hang out with a guy like that who is he
to judge you and I'm like well he's
actually he's the only one who can
so I mean he's the best he's great we've
been sitting on this one for a while uh
I'm glad it's finally out there he's so
funny so interesting I'm glad you guys
are here couple things to mention up top
we moved our YouTube channel so if you
like watching this podcast on
youtube.com uh we decided to kind of
clean things up make uh Pete Holmes on
YouTube kind of the sketch standup
Channel and now you made it weird when
that's the name of the channel you made
it weird will be its own Standalone
podcast Channel kind of keep things
clean do me a favor do me a favor would
you do me a favor just subscribe just
subscribe like subscribe all that stuff
so we can start building that channel
and help people find the show discover
the show but also keep that sweet sweet
show flowing into your sweet sweet feed
so go on YouTube and find the channel
you made it weird and uh like And
subscribe and all that stuff people are
always saying um but that's exciting so
check that out um what else please watch
my special it's called I am not for
everyone it's on Netflix uh worked
really hard on it hope you like it and
also try a pizza pck it's it's the it's
the giving season it's the giving season
so why not give your favorite weirdo
some pizza piics and what better to give
than something to make them beautiful
radiant glowing healthy vibrant from our
friends at Living Libations I'm always
saying living Libations is a great way
to support the show because you can get
something big you can do what Val and I
did which is overhaul our entire
medicine cabinet our whole Beauty
regimen with skin care Hair Care teeth
care eye care baby care with a natural
natural meaning you'll recognize the
ingredients High high and alternative to
random chemical nightmares but you can
also maybe you don't want to do a full
overhaul you can just buy a tongue
scrubber buy a tongue scraper support
the show support your your mouth health
and get a tongue scraper meaning this is
a great way use that promo code support
the show support your body cuz like I
always say I've been very careful about
what I eat but I wasn't being careful
about what I was putting on my body
which of course ends up in your body and
these things can be very very toxic very
very unhealthy living Libations makes
natural alternatives that are not only
easy to pronounce and understand but are
bad ass their exfoliating uh face wash
is the most powerful gritty best working
face wash scrub that I've ever found in
my life it's incredible use it before
you shave makes it such a better
experience also their best their shaving
cream is incredible so natural and
wonderful you can rub it into your face
after you're done shaving and use it as
an after shave that's how hydrating and
wonderful it is I also use their best
skin ever moisturizer we use their love
the sun zinc based sunblock for Leela to
keep those chemicals off our baby
believe me whatever you're using in your
daily Beauty regimen living Libations
has a Wonder wonderful alternative that
is good for your body so get into it go
to living li.com
/we support your body support the show
you you get 15% off living lib.com weird
and no surprise this one's empty of
course cuz I am always drinking magic
mind magic mind is a productivity drink
it's not an energy drink it has matcha
so there's about as much caffeine as
half a cup of coffee but it has
adaptogens to bring you down to round
out the edges of that sometimes too much
caffeine experience softens the caffeine
and then it also has a wonderful blend
of neotropic that help you create help
you think basically magic mind is Flow
State in a bottle I travel with it in a
little baggie so I can get through TSA
with it uh that's how important it is to
me I take it before my shows I take it
before my podcasts I take it before I
face my inbox sometimes you just want to
get into that dual state of up and
relaxed it's the perfect flow state
drink to drop you into flow get you
working fight procrastination fight
brain fog and also drink less coffee I
drink it with my coffee which is my
buddy James that's what he did as well
to balance out that coffee but I also
take it by itself sometimes it's all I
need magic mind is a magical Elixir it
gets you dialed in not wired total
GameChanger as you guys know I
discovered it and then reached out to
them to work together so this is not
just some empty none of these these are
things that I love it's not just reading
copy I'm telling you about something
some things that have made my life
better and Magic might is absolutely one
of those we have a wonderful offer for
weirdos at magicmine go to magic
mind.co weird and use my discount code
if check out weird for a limited 20% off
your first order do yourself a favor and
subscribe because once you try it the
more you use it the more it builds the
better it works absolute Game Changer
Magic m./ weird and use promo code weird
at checkout all right everybody be sure
to subscribe on YouTube to the new you
made it weird Channel and in the
meantime enjoy my friend Malik alisol
get into it I really like what it's kind
of sad you ever have someone compliment
you and you get sad because it's so Meek
oh look at how it's so it's like are you
about to cry it's so nice it was your
garage you know I think Lou oh my God
God redo the whole thing she doesn't
want me talking about the scandalized
comedian Lou CK but Lou did have a bit
where like somebody's so happy for you
it sounds like they're in pain they're
like
oh oh God it's very funny what is this
here that's for you that's what is this
the magic mind that's your magic mind I
chug this what do I do with shake it
first I'm going to try you don't have to
shake it in the jerk off
motion there you go there's only one way
to shake things that's true that's true
but I but you don't have to make the
face when I was a kid I was like you
know what it had to be the best part of
being well no I can't say that on the
back of of mentioning Louie but I was
just like what was the masturbation
policy for caveman like were they
ashamed of
it I'm just saying we're cavemen we're
cavemen pre Society if I feel it right
now yeah we're hunting you're a little
tense and you jerk it is it like blowing
your nose this is real this is a real
question
I'm taking it as real yeah no I'm not
joking at all but I when I was young I
was so obsessed with masturbation I was
like it must have been great to be a
caveman because before like the church
or anything maybe it was just like
waving
hello just you just do it any I think
probably you were just always a little
bit playing with it I don't even know if
I don't even know if it was I feel like
it's probably like our like our society
make that we make it ritualistic now
because we need because we need to go
away from people but before we probably
just were like just constantly always
touching a little just a little just a
little D couple Jacks here cou what
taking a [__] like if we're C sh you
were you had stuff coming out of every
every hole at all times give it a chug
little bit of grapefruit flavor magic
mind whoa delicious I'm glad you drank
it the episodes are better when people
drink it I wanted to drink it no you
mentioned it that at Largo stop being so
neat you can just throw it away I want
it to look nice I want this whole thing
to keep it looks so nice in here it
looks great in here now I'm realizing
this I'm like is this voice anti-semitic
cuz it's a very old joke you're so far
away is that I'm trying to make sure is
he in the camera I'm just trying to
think fun would it looks I'm just trying
to find my you be you Boston University
man be you I just want to make sure the
camera is getting you you're okay yeah
you're so is this voice not okay anymore
I do I do an old Jew all the time old
Jew voice is one old Jew voice an old
Jewish voice don't say old Jew voice old
Jew voice does sound like a voice over
there raer like Old Dirty Bastard old
Jew voice GH he was the guy yeah the
wuang clan was
like next next time you can do a Next
freestyle let me in
[Music]
there there's a your Hat's too big I'm
going to walk away from this area as as
you're a Muslim and I'm not
we're walking away from this rft we're
walking away right away hands up so
happy to see did you just say God is
great God is great okay subtitles on I'm
here to translate God is you got it
there's not a lot I can translate God is
great but it's on I think it directly
translates to God is big really Allah
but God Is Bigger like is greater yeah
well my daughter's five and sometimes
I'll say like um great meaning large and
she just does that's like a big loop to
throw her on oh I see cuz she's new to
the language and she's like I I forget
what the example was but I was like and
that's great and she's like it's not
great and I was like cuz it wasn't good
it was something bad that was like a
great big evil or
something I don't know I'm talking to my
daughters about
great there's a lot to be afraid of baby
have a great day it's a crazy place was
there anything else like that that uh oh
yeah like other like a word that you use
well this is in my ACT but she calls
Chopsticks Chomp sticks which I'm just
like that's so much more correct Chomp
sticks yeah you don't chop with them you
got to do this to Seinfeld you don't
chop with them you Chom with them honey
they're Chomp sticks why are they called
Chopsticks who called them chop we
called them Chopsticks they didn't
Chinese people didn't call them
Chopstick there's no way they called
them Chopsticks Katie I hate to Rogan
you right now but Jamie would you look
that up you got a little something right
there I just want to let you know
beforehand no you got a little yes you
do no I don't all right I like the way
you
think where is it this is always hard
where is it you w okay yeah yep I'm
going up there whoa you you sniped that
I got it good you felt where it was I
didn't even point you I just went like
you got something we got it well it was
bulbous you felt it Chopsticks all right
so it says
it's unclear but it's widely believed to
have originated from the Chinese pigeon
English term Chop Chop meaning quickly
or wait wait wait which isn't
appropriate you can't say Chop Chop like
and I'm all for that this ain't this
ain't the guy going we can't even say
Chop Chop anymore I get it no saying
Chop Chop but we do say Chopsticks like
quick from chow chow another pigeon word
meaning food chow chow what does pigeon
mean like I don't know I've never heard
that pigeon Chinese Chinese pigeon
English Chinese pigeon
English sounds racist it all sounds like
it's from rac.com
yeah what yeah what do you want racist.
comom over there don't go to races.com
yeah it just redirects to lemonparty.com
Chopsticks from the from the pigeon
Chopsticks I don't yeah that pigeon
Chinese pigeon English sounds not okay
pigeon English yeah it sounds like
you're pecking at the language you don't
speak it yeah those those those head
bobbing how are the Arab cuz you speak
Arabic yeah how are you guys
arab-speaking people with the
attempters because it's not an easy
language you know what from what I can
tell it's mostly lowercase
chz it's andj it's all and just I just
mean not only is it hard to speak but
it's not in the uh what is the word the
script it's not in the western it's not
the same alphabet a lot of there's a lot
of letters that I Arabs like it when
non-arabs attempt Arabic we think that's
great we think not it's not like an eye
roll no we get flattered I'd say if it's
like if if someone's making an effort
yeah if someone's making an actual
effort we're we're psyched about it but
not like France where they're
like or they roll your eyes and you guys
are like speak English every know
they'll get their friends that be like
look at this guy yeah it's
it's oh my God there we go I'm just
trying to impress you yeah that's all I
got one beer one tea that's amazing this
is from from Israel did you know I said
in Israel did we talk about that you
told you told me quickly that you were
you spent the Ramadan in Israel that's
what it was and I was so impressed that
Suliman would smoke a cigarette before
he would eat and you told me that voman
you can't smoke I'm glad you brought
that up why can't you smoke because you
can't really intake anything what about
air I'm not trying to be funny I never
thought about it like that I mean you're
intaking light sunlight Vitamin
D all of all of Islam falls apart
because of this podcast everyone's like
wait I fall apart I fall away you
disintegrate um no of course you you're
not supposed to ingest you're not
supposed to affect your being what about
coffee no coffee no it's got to be a
tense that's hard it is hard no
cigarettes no coffee no cigarettes no
coffee 30 days no water yeah no wonder
he was lighting up yeah at night he lit
up at night I which I took to be like
what a [__] gangster move it that he
was like I'm not even going to eat cuz I
was like I can't believe you're not
immediately I was so American I was in
college I was like I'd have a piece of
cake under a spotlight you you know like
to eat at the end of the day like ready
waiting for now I go a day without
eating it's not a big deal at all but at
that time in my life I couldn't
understand I do it all the time when
it's not Ramadan but there's something
about Ramadan that makes you like you're
so yeah in it that you're like it is
just part of what you're doing right
it's um I I thought the collective might
make it easier it does it makes parts of
it easier but it you are it is on your
mind yeah it's still on your mind you're
like in like a mode of like I'm like
you're in the Meer of not doing things
you're like you're seeing what your your
uh your factory settings are that's kind
of what Ramadan is to me is like getting
back to the factory settings doing like
a reset that's so I was just thinking
about that like your natural state
without like let's be honest a lot of a
lot of these things are drugs and food
is you know I'm not I'm like the N
billionth person to point this out but
food is changing your state and when you
get naked like I I fast twice a week
which I found out uh Muhammad fasted on
the first and four on Mondays Mondays
and Thursdays I think yeah yeah believe
so which is what I do
so everyone's converting it's the hot
new thing right now everybody
everybody's in are people everybody's
Muslim is there a is it spiking a lot of
people really yeah a lot of people yeah
Katie can you make it a little cooler in
here yeah wearing this D how is where
I'm holding the mic it's great just like
stand up comedy you're good
I sometimes hold it to would you put on
69 the funniest
number great it's actually the only
funny number I don't chuckle at 420 69
gets me every time yeah no 420 I'm
serious about go well let's go there you
used to what
okay you're so much more than a Muslim
but I'm very interested in you had a
period of no drugs alcohol pork then you
had a time where you were eating no pork
but you were doing drugs and alcohol and
now you don't do drugs and alcohol or
report now yeah now tell me what was
that what happened there was after a rum
Springer it was solo Mission I kind of
it was after the Islamic school
everybody kind of so you went to Islamic
high school I went to Islamic
kindergarten until the 12th grade grade
12 the same SCH Canada same school the
whole time I never went to another
school all Muslims all Muslim School
gender separated um we had class
together when when we pray they prayed
behind us um but pretty much the whole
yeah it was I was I went to school with
a lot of the people that I went to I
graduated with the same people I went to
kindergarten with a lot of people wow
yeah are you you still know these people
yeah I still know them it's going to
have to be that way I mean that was your
whole childhood I'll always know them
yeah and uh it was just kind of a thing
of where like I was
in like it was kind of like I knew that
I wanted to do something I guess maybe
in entertainment and then that kind of
was like I was like I don't know if this
is it was like hard to like there was no
way to get to it from my school so I had
to go outside of it and then from there
I just started to meet different types
of kids theater kids exactly what I'm
sure your parents were worried would
happen 100% got corrupted by theater
kids yeah you okay so they look as a
parent I side with parents so much more
now yeah they're trying to give you like
a certain uh safe cuz let's say drugs
and alcohol dangerous I mean not full
stop but they are a lot of a lot of
[__] weed is a gateway drug for some
people it can be it can be and alcohol
the the statistics on alcohol and murder
and alcohol and sexual assault are
staggering yes and pardon the pun but
they're sobering they're like what do
what do we yeah I know let's just let's
just eat that's a cup of coffee right
there that was a cup of coffee right
there but I mean like you know there's
all this horrible stuff happening and
when you look at it how much of it was
fueled potentially even encouraged like
the rage is encouraged by alcohol and
like you know it that's what it does it
inhibits you anyway so your parents
wanted to protect you from that they put
you in the school and then you were like
I want to be in Showbiz let's slow this
story down when and why did you want to
be in Showbiz I think I just um I don't
know it was just kind of like a a way
that I felt like I was moving I don't
know if there was ever like a moment I
think I liked Power Rangers when I was a
kid I just I just think I like something
a little off about the Power Rangers cuz
it's dubbed you know what I mean I
didn't know that until later neither but
it's compelling you're kind of like why
is it so like the blue ranger would act
when he was you know clearly him meaning
not dubbed and then it would cut to the
fight scenes and you're like I don't
believe that guy moves like that yeah I
don't believe a lot of them and then
it's like Rita repulsa what's she doing
Rita repulsa's on a whole other thing
wait who is Rita repulser she's the
villain she's the one who was like the
Rangers oh yeah she was and she was
dubbed she was obviously dubbed which is
like they didn't they could have redone
read repuls that would have made it that
would have made Meer Rita ralser it's I
remember yeah so you liked you like
Power Rangers I liked Power Rangers and
were you a funny I was funny in school I
always was just I was always trying to
get people off track and everything like
that and then I just I don't know I just
uh I think there was like a moment in
high school where I was like I would
always quote things you know classic
memory for jokes memory for Stu I would
quote things that I saw I was always
talking about comedy and then I remember
there was like a To Kill a Mocking Bird
uh we were studying to Kill a Mocking
Bird and then we had a um we were going
to do like a mock trial we were going to
like act out a version of it but it was
just like the the teacher kind of gave
the as a direction of like like we're
going to just kind of do a little bit of
a presentation and I showed up in like
overalls and like too way too much wait
so you weren't the main guy you didn't
didn't come in a white suit with a I I
think I was being a lawyer but in my
head I was like the lawyers were
overalls back then everybody had
overalls everybody had overalls it just
depending if you did both buckles up or
not if you know one down let people know
not only do I overall party I one Buckle
unbuckled party like that's a guy who's
making his own Moon gosh
gosh I just Ash Ash gosh I just ash I
keep the gosh on yeah the gosh the gosh
over my
shoulder wait this is a weird tangent
but Mickey Mouse has suspender buttons
you know what I'm talking about like he
has those two yellow buttons on his
pants they're up they're here yeah he's
got two buttons on his pants but there's
no so I just immediately jumped to this
theory he is wearing suspenders but
they're black and they're they're
blending in they're blending into him
I'm I'm realizing I forget what Mickey
Mouse looks like right now three circles
were 90% there yeah okay reg uh you know
human body all black mhm red pans two
yellow buttons what are those buttons
for those are suspenders he's wearing
suspenders but they're black this is
going to break the internet this is yeah
for zoom in you can see the tinyest
Bulge we thought they were nipples for
all these years and now oh he just has
low low sagging yellow
nipples old low yellow nipple Mickey oh
boy
indeed sorry that's so stupid we're
having fun though are you googling it K
I'm just kidding does Mickey Mouse have
Mickey Mouse suspender Theory produces
zero
results well on racist. comom they say
says it's pigeon English which even as I
say it I'm like there's no way I can say
that is that pigeon English nope nobody
ever said that lovingly yeah yeah
tenderly asking I'm sorry are you
speaking pigeon English
pigeon okay um you Power Rangers Mickey
Mouse for no reason came up suspenders
oh Ash gosh you showed up for the play
and took it like really serious it was
yeah it was just like a class
presentation and then the teacher was
kind of like it was the first teacher
who kind of told me everybody else had
an emphasis on like you got to go to
university after after high school you
got to figure that out and then and you
know it was it was very University get
married like that that was the the path
and then
she told me she was like you could you
know you could maybe make a go of
something like this she told me she's
like he's like you could be maybe an
actor and I was like oh I didn't even
really realized I was like he saw your
razzled Dazzle yeah that she was like
you know there's something she's like
you did something there she was like
there's something that you just did
there and then she said that and then I
remember her telling you she what did
you do I object I think I did an
accident you did I think I went a little
bit I say you take that a step back yeah
I was fog horn in the middle I yeah I
don't know what I don't remember what it
was anymore but and then I remember her
telling me that she's like you know you
don't have to go to university and I
never could other people see this
teacher cuz this sounds like an angel
this sounds like somebody who was like
Malik yeah standup comedy it's like no
that this is a hallucination you had I a
lot of yeah I have a lot of moments like
that where it's like it's just is this
just like a guidance yeah it feels like
kind of like being like LED along yeah
like that what
held along what jumped to mind I don't
know just every like on all the moments
like they feel like like um quite like
linear like from there I started working
at like I just like worked at Walmart
like out of high school and then I would
just like look at DVDs all day and just
kind of like look at actors and just
kind of just think about it yeah and I
just hyped myself up I remember I looked
I was looking at The Count of Monte
Cristo the movie and then I kind of uh
at this time I was like wanting to be
actor and then I was like Googling like
theater companies in Cal CU there was no
we tried to do a play at the Islamic
school another teacher kind of I think
started a drama class for me so that I
could do it oh my God and we did this
play called the paperbag Bandit and can
we just pause and point out how
atrocious the other children must have
been oh my God they were like Malik has
a little Talent let's get him in here
and then there's just like seven Rubes
oh man they were nobody could keep a
straight I was I was I was being like
guys can we please be [__]
professional are you not [__]
professional I screaming people yeah
amazing so a teacher another teacher
noticed your talent teacher who came in
uh a white lady sometimes we would have
a white teacher and she'd come in and
try to shake up they have to be Muslim
no sometimes we had a lot of Muslim
teachers but sometimes we'd have a
non-muslim teacher and she came in and
she was like the art teacher and she you
know and she was like you know like we
could she could see that I wanted to do
it really bad and then she started a a
drama class
and we were in the middle of it and it
was it was like it was like a romance
and then I remember we got about like
halfway through like rehearsing it and
then the Islamic Studies teacher came
and shut it down he's said we don't do
this kind of thing here so then it was
over wait why did he shut it down just
cuz it's sort we don't do that yeah we
don't we don't do romance in with like
these kids basically and we weren't
going to like we weren't going to like
make out in front of the but theater is
look obviously I'm all for it but I
understand the guy being like this is
weird this is weird I understand my
parents I understand all of it it's like
the part of me that understands you not
wanting you to drink and do drugs and go
in a show business I can understand
we're it's so normal but if you are
trying to kind of like I don't know
shelter people or what do you think the
intent of a guy shutting down a theater
program is I don't know I think
everybody was just worried I truly think
everybody was very worried about me cuz
they didn't know cuz I just wouldn't do
anything that anybody asked me to do I
really was like no and then nobody had
any frame of reference people only had
examples of what happens when this
doesn't go well yeah explode it just
deteriorates and you drugs and you I had
a cousin who went down a really bad path
and he was a very funny kid and then he
but he he got like lost in in drugs and
he's still he's still there you know
he's still he's still in that path so
like my friend saw hanging over your
head yeah yeah they they always were
like like when they would find something
or like see what I was doing they was
just like so scared that was going to
end up this reminds me of like Arnold
Schwarzenegger so it's not obviously a
completely different culture but I
watched that documentary and like he'd
have those magazine like bodybuilding
magazines and his dad was like what like
what yeah what is this and again I I was
trying to relate to the dad like I I
obviously relate to Arnold it was his
interest it was his passion but like
things are weird like if you're not
familiar with a bodybuilding magazine or
your son being like straight s the China
you just like like your Poor Dad and
then and then this cousin he was
talented or he is talented yeah he used
to get up and entertain the whole family
so like look I don't know why I'm being
an apologist for sort of like old old
school kind of philosophies or or or
World Views World Views I feel for it
but I yeah it's it's it's unfamiliar
it's scared it's it's trying to make a
make understanding in a world that's
changing a lot of not from here or
they're like the world has changed so
much since they've been alive they're
trying to grasp onto something right
that's right but also like a performer
like when I explain standup to people
I'm like it's like free cocaine it's
like you do a set like you're set at
Largo the other and it was so great
we're all just backstage and you are
high we're like High people I have to
imagine you were high I was I felt great
and then we're talking afterward yeah
and we talk like High people like I mean
like if you were bugging us like bugging
the room you would be like these people
are probably on cocaine even though you
know Kum and I were there and we've been
doing this this performance drug longer
so I feel like I can you were very chill
I don't mean it that way I just mean
like we can kind of be like kind of
acting normal but inside it's the fourth
of July you know you're like lit up I'm
standing up I'm moving around yeah I'm
stretching you you fit in perfectly I'm
just saying like the correlation between
a guy who gets up in front of people and
this is really me being like like really
sort of rigid I guess but if you get up
in front of people looking for Laughs
that is looking for your value and
looking for like a hit of something that
you're lacking from outside right so
it's people laughs and then it's not
that big of a jump to go to well alcohol
is sort of like a laughing audience like
I can fill that hole with this and and
look at how much drugs and alcohol is in
this so I it's not crazy to say this guy
isn't and I would say this about me this
guy I'm pointing to myself is not
drawing from his own Wellspring I'm
looking for it from you right now I'm
looking for it from the audience I'll
look for it on stage I found some
balance there but seeing the the pattern
from that kind of addiction to another
kind of addiction I could see why your
parents would be less concerned if you
weren't kind of like shopping around for
a feeling yeah does that make sense yeah
it does make sense they just didn't know
what to make of any of it they didn't
know what they they're just like yeah
Hollywood is is these sick people and
they do drugs and they and they do and
and and hey and we're talking about that
and they're not wrong sometimes you know
that is that happens well it also you
know you're considerably younger than me
but the Hollywood that your parents saw
was if you're a Muslim you're the
terrorist and you know it was all
painted pretty poorly yeah but yeah my
my mom you're like I want to get in bed
with the people it's like oh no I was
like I don't think I look I don't look
like a terrorist enough to even get that
part maybe I'll play a white guy is
disappointing you're ready to sell out
and go for it hard nobody will even let
me they're like n I'm trying to do
Baconator commercials they won't let me
can you do old Jewish
voice it does it doesn't work okay so
I'm just I'm I'm having an easy time
understanding your parents surprisingly
yeah I
mean and I mean jumping ahead now
they're kind of they don't know what to
make of it still but now they're like
like um they're like excited about it
but just don't know they're just kind of
just just general support that's good
yeah like my mom yesterday I told her I
was coming to do this and she was like
she was like making Dua she was like
praying she said
uh funny things to say she said God
please allow him to utter funny things
oh my God which is not like a prayer
that exists like she like going Ro she's
going Offroad but that's beautiful yeah
that's great I I see my
parents efforting to understand and
appreciate and and that really warms my
heart I've said this before but one of
the closest times I ever felt to my
parents was when they signed a release
for HBO because I was writing characters
based on them oh yeah and they were
nervous the legal department wanted them
to sign a release and they did and my
parents were like they kept saying as
long as it's funny they it's like say
whatever you want as long as it's funny
Tred and I was like oh my God
this is really special for me so like
this is this conversation is helping me
understand even how weird things are for
for them yeah I I I feel for them I I
think I stressed them out a lot really
and yeah I think with all this stuff I
think I was just kind of trying to like
find something yeah I think I I think
also going to the Islamic school when I
was a kid I also like there was like I
don't know if like I was explained to
properly like what I should be feeling
when I was praying oh interesting tell
me what do you mean mean like there was
always like a like am I praying right
you know what I mean like is the feeling
is what's supposed to be happening
happening to me I used to try look I'm
just saying this to relate not go off on
a tangent I used to pray for the gift of
tongues would speak in tongues not
really in my church but yeah I knew
that's that's in the Bible it's in Acts
you know it's like that's a thing you
can be overcome with the spirit and you
speak in a in a a language we don't
understand yeah and I wanted that so bad
just because I wanted proof that I was
doing it correctly and I'd pray in
private it never came it never happened
so I know exactly what you're talking
about like is this is this what I'm
supposed to be feeling is this right
like I'm looking around kind of a little
bit but I didn't see it look I didn't
see it in a lot of the grown-ups I
didn't see them having like Revelation
or or even just peace this is what I
meant is that I'm like we're all talking
about this spiritual thing of like
getting to this place but I don't think
this is what we're like it doesn't feel
like it's it's actually what we're after
in this way I was like okay if we're
going to be these spiritual people it
didn't feel very spiritual it felt very
rigid and I was like looking for like
maybe a connection yeah there was a
whole thing of like we' be praying cuz
we had prayer every day in school we
pray and then I remember the way that
they explained prayer to us is like half
of your half of your heart is in in love
for Allah and reverence for Allah and
then half of it is fear for Allah so it
was just explaining to me like that so I
would just kind of like be like sitting
there and just be just thinking about
that and be like what is that what is
those two things multiply into what
feeling does that get and I was like I
don't think and I'll be trying not to
like lose my focus on that and I'm like
I don't think this is it I just was like
yeah I have a lot of feelings about what
you just said and and it's hard to say
them because I don't want to be
disrespectful to a tradition not that
every Muslim is the same but
that uh perspective on God is really
hard for me to hear like what do you
mean the the like let's be scared and I
think it was a lot of worry around me
and bargaining well yeah kumel told me
about an exercise that or somebody had
somebody at some point in his life
explained to him that like walking to
heaven was like walking on a razor wire
above hell and like and it's as hard to
walk like a mile of razor wire and you
have to walk to God and your faith keeps
you and your faith keeps you balanced
but it's like any mistake in you I know
and Christi have that to by the way
scares the [__] out of you sinners in
the eyes of an Angry God hands of an
Angry God so Jonathan Edwards I think is
his name says we're like spiders in
God's hand and he's holding the spider
above a fire and the spider keeps biting
God's hand so there this is in every
faith has some version of the fear
that's why it's hard for me to hear it's
not it's not just what that might have
done to you it's like what ideas like
that did to me well yeah it feels like
in even in like the text and then in the
parents and then in the teachers is all
the same thing it's just like it's a way
to get children which is even just like
humans I'm like going to count as
children in this is just getting them to
understand yeah how do we get like
humans to understand this like this
thing that's not to understand right
right fire hot yeah ow right that kind
of thing so that was I felt like like
like and I feel like that's what was
going on with the school was like I
think at that time maybe they've gotten
their and there was a lot of good that
came out of the school but this is just
kind of how I was taking it at the time
was that I was like I'm right there with
you know how to
get hundreds of kids whose parents came
from another country and now they're
like their parents desperately want them
to have a piece of the culture that they
had when they were growing up how do we
get it into these kids that are seeing
everything else the World opening up and
you can do anything how do we get them
to be like no this is the thing a little
bit of fear helps just kind of keep you
there okay I like this this is
compassion for that side yeah if you
want
to when I say sell I mean propagate a
idea it's very hard to do that without
fear and advertising is doing this all
the time I'm I'm really just trying to
broaden this concept yeah isn't like
maybe this is a stretch but it's
like a car
commercial there's a little bit of fear
there if you don't have the right car
how will people see you wouldn't you say
that's like a it's a pack mentality you
won't be revered or no one will mate
with you right by show that that's not
the most obvious example but with with
Christianity I'll say we're going to
sell Christianity right okay well first
of all I need to get you on the hook so
I'm going to say you were born a sinner
yeah right there so we're off we're the
need is there yes if I'm going to sell
you magic mind I'm going to be like do
you have a hard time focusing it's very
similar you don't have enough yeah
you're you're and by the way obviously I
love magic mind you just drank it but
I'm saying all advertising is kind of
like what are you looking for so
Christianity is like are you you need
Redemption and here's proof here's a
very old story about how you were born a
sinner uh well we have it you need to
believe this and and and follow these
precepts and all this sort of stuff and
then the final step is put a clock on it
this is for a limited time only the MC
RB it's basically the MCB which I know
you've never had and neither have I no
but
uh Christianity is the McRib
Christianity is similar to the MCB in
that the limited time is you'll die and
you could die any day isn't that [__]
nuts sometime I think about this all the
time you you go this could be this could
be it [__] crazy so it goes you never
know when you're going to die this is
why I I get so sad it used to be angry
but now it's a little bit more sad when
I see Billboards especially in certain
parts of the country that just say like
if you die today do you know where you
would go I'm like that's just the purest
line of fear yeah and it's even coming
from a place
maybe of well-meaning like maybe they
mean it we got to get them to eat this
MCB we got to get the most people to eat
the MCB all at once we're we're trying
to feed everybody yeah and we have to
force feed it to them and we're not sure
if they know how to eat and then you put
aside true conversion so that's what
we're saying when we're talking about
joy and peace and patience you know what
I mean I'm sure you've met a lot of
spiritual people that you can just tell
yeah like oh they're they're died like d
ye e d they they got soaked in God and
now they are are just they're converted
they're new move the world way easier
they did it they don't have the fear
they don't have the right oh yeah and
everybody that meets God in my opinion
meets a lover not a Tormentor but yeah
these these things like if you're over
here and you were taught with fear MH
and you're taught that if you die uh you
could go to hell so you're basically now
you're looking at it and I remember this
being explained to me when I was growing
up Christian it's like somebody has
their foot stuck in the train track
you're not going to go up to to them and
and be like you know wait for God and
look for God and everything you're just
going to get your [__] foot out
they're like I don't need to and you're
like you're going to get hit by a train
you just get that mentality does that
make sense yeah that energy of uh of you
have to do something now now yeah yeah
cuz we got to sell these mrebs yeah and
I think that that permeates that that
feeling kind of uh was in me I had that
feeling my parents had that feeling I
had it I just recently heard something
that made me um kind of like it just
kind of changed my perception about that
which is like don't let the
ferociousness of modernity Force you uh
to rush through things you should take
your time with Wow which is like which
is all of it we should be taking our
time and like stop doing things as a
means to an end and just do do them yeah
there's a part of me that I don't know
why I always in a like it feels like
time is running out I've always had that
feeling can I add to that pending Doom a
little bit okay so look at okay we we
now we all take our our photos on our
cameras and then we just have them yeah
so in the 80s before you were born you'd
take pictures and then you'd go to CVS
and you'd drop them off this is an
errand yeah then you'd have to go back
and wait in line and pick them up so
let's let's just be conservative like
and say that with an hour two hours
maybe so we're all saving 2 hours so
shouldn't we have we have photos we
don't have to develop them where did
those two hours go why aren't I straight
up kicking it in a hammock if I was
hammocking for two hours a week yeah I'd
look younger you feel so much better
yeah it used to but they're gone they
get replaced he should take you weeks to
get anywhere years to get anywhere we
should have so much time Trail we should
have so much time we should and we
should but this is this is where you see
the lack of um value they we don't put
value on leisure time or quiet time
which is what prayer you know one aspect
of prayer is a quiet centering time
relax yeah and you know the Jewish faith
I think has done a really good job with
with the Sabbath it's like take a whole
day like and we're all going to do it
that's pretty that's pretty dope and I
see a lot of benefit in that and that's
in Ramadan too you're just supposed to
just like let it all go for a month just
whatever incredible truly incredible and
that that's a cultural that's a culture
valuing what in the west we're not we're
not valuing we're like well let save the
time just to [__] what what are we
doing yeah we're like mortgaging the
present for a future that we don't even
know we're not even mortgaging the
present for a future we're not even
promised is [__] you're 27 that's
[__]
dope K looks it up and she goes no that
he stole that yeah WC field said that
that's weird of all the people yeah okay
love that into it the we're talking
about a an Arnold Palmer of fear and and
love and why we can kind of understand
the desperation to get you indoctrinated
into not only a faith but a culture
right I mean it's not it's a people it's
a place yeah it's not just a philosophy
it it's it's your you know your I don't
it sounds too severe to say your
bloodline but I can see why people want
you to be like them like how they like
my parents and the people around me like
the teachers they're like want we want
you to be like us so that we felt like
we did what we were trying to do right
which was try to carry a tradition on so
if you're doing something that we don't
recognize did we all [__] up right did
everybody [__] up and I think my parents
had that feeling of like we blew it cuz
he's not like us it's like the whole
culture is trying to have you know we
this is not why you should reproduce but
part of the reason why people reproduce
is this like immortality you know what I
mean it's like I will be happier when
I'm dying to know that my genes and also
you know you see this in the animal
kingdom they're doing it there's an urge
to keep you going yes it's almost like
the whole so many faiths I'm not just
Islam but so many faiths are trying to
have a
baby that will continue on otherwise if
you don't and you tell me if you felt
this if you don't continue it on I know
a lot of my Jewish friends feel this way
you're like letting them you're letting
them down you know you're letting them
die you're letting them yeah exactly
you're going like actually I'm I'm going
to ride a hoverboard and hit a vape you
know they're like
no right no yeah no please please bust
inside bust
inside oh that's them I guess so they
they want you to have the me please
guess but but but also don't you're
having Islam sex with a condom is the
problem like you're not fully committing
I was which by the way I was thinking
about this on the way in because a
friend of mine uh a Jewish friend of
mine I was using their sink and whatever
I was worried that they were kosher and
then they were like we're not Kosher and
I was like of course you're not Kosher
nobody's [__] kosher but then like
this same friend would be like you must
marry a Jew like but I'm like yeah which
is it we're not look this is every Faith
this is this is Christianity as well I
have to marry a Christian but like are
you doing the thing no we we're picking
the the hits cable yeah we're picking
cable we're kind of picking the channels
I'm just trying to be less rigid about
it also just now I'm just trying to see
I'm just trying to go with the feelings
of it and like feel what makes me feel
like I'm like walking in the light
that's all that's it like at this point
now it was just a lot of like being
scared and feeling like I was doing
something wrong I um I kind of have the
feeling now that I'm like there's really
in a larger sense there's just nothing
that could go wrong kind of thing like
just I love that just that it is all
fine do you know what I mean no matter
what happens even if my life doesn't go
the way I want to that's not that's also
it's fine I I just can't believe you're
27 it took me so long to figure
out I had like a I don't know how to
like a realization let's just call it
that I was like there's so much less to
do than we think which is God is greater
you know what I mean yeah God is greater
than your little your little to-dos that
you have to do around little [__]
you have to that's what I'm yes I'm just
so happy to hear you saying this just
because I know the piece that it's given
me I'm working on a joke right now where
I'm like God loves me just the way I am
isn't that annoying I was like it was so
much more exciting wasn't better but
when I thought God was like I was like
Jason Bourne and God was in the room
with all the computers going like he's
choking it he's choking off like send
the Angels send the Angels you know send
the shame send the guilt send send the
fear constant like the amount of power
in that ego setup that you have over God
the reason I say ego it's it's an ego
trip I'm like I'm I'm pissing off God
right now yeah you know like what yeah
yeah yeah it's it's it's it's ridiculous
to think that uh that it would that that
you could affect it in that in that way
I guess yeah that you could bite God's
hand like you're a spider and you're
like I'm going to bite God's hand he's
so pissed yeah that I just said pissed
yes and I'm like the thing that did it
is over there it did it just to go like
like having an ant farm and being like
this [__] ant you know or whatever if
that's your view of God as like an
observer what a what a crazy what a
crazy game for for God to
play yeah to me it's just like like it's
that that's that's a tough thing to
reckon with the Free Will of it all yeah
you know and how much is like written
and how much is like what we get to to
do here like I don't know like that's
yeah I'm I'm still trying to figure that
out I'm still trying to figure out how
much of it is like
um in your brain yeah and how much of it
is a game and how much of it is just
like to take seriously and how okay look
at look at AI right and we go it's just
a program we go it's it's just a program
you give it the choices it has this
impetus it has this history it has and
it will choose this over that because it
knows it's run that test aren't we just
going around running tests and going
like when I can't connect with my
parents a phrase that that I I just got
reminded of it something that I
said um that gives me a lot of pieces if
I was them I'd be them and I've said
this a million times but if I was your
dad or or pick anybody it's hard because
everybody goes we'll pick Hitler I'm
like okay
[__] can you calm down just for a
second yeah yeah but if I was a friend
that I'm having an argument with and I
don't agree with them of course it's
like the most obvious thing in the world
but it's the most profound thing in the
world if you had their brain yeah their
past their physiology their everything
their psychology you'd be them you just
have yours it's like you just have a
different operating system you have
different experiences you had different
parents you had different place but that
just made you you but don't you see how
arbitrary both like when you're driving
on the highway and you see a a sticker
on a car that you disagree with uhhuh I
used to be like [__] it now I go if I
was them I'd be them I can't tell you
the piece that this gives me if you and
I grew up and blah blah blah would' be
would have different feelings about this
this or this just because of our
environment yeah so there's a
certain and and then what happens when
someone from it's like you going into
Show Business what happens when somebody
from I don't want to put down any area
but let's just say from the Deep South
moves to New York City do they become
more liberal often yeah often not I'm
not saying a full wash but once you
start knowing a lot more different
groups and and if a person from
Manhattan moves to that part do they
become more this yes it's like we're all
so malleable we're all membrane we're
programmed yes ex we're
so affected yes we're so easily affected
and we're back to the MC rib this is why
advertising works and we're like I don't
do that sort of stuff [__] you dude as
soon as Everyone's Watching Ted lasso
you just watch Ted lasso you [__] that's
free will there's your free will and it
makes you happy like they wanted you to
that's right and you go no I just like
good things each [__] you couldn't stand
being in the ninth elevator and you
didn't know about an optimistic soccer
coach like that's you you're not even
there you're in AI you're just a blank
slate and the world can affect you in a
million different ways but right but you
are just this thing and you like that's
I feel like that's what it is I'm trying
to get to is I'm trying to like remove
as much as I can to just see what is the
thing back to the fasting what is the
thing yeah I mean like I quit nicotine I
mean I'm trying to quit everything and
just try to see what it is yeah and like
see what affects me the most and like
what because I could just feel myself
getting pulled around all the time and
that is to me
spirituality uh is the interest in that
Baseline like what is what is the nature
of pure being the hum yeah the hum the
hum what are you if you let all of it go
cuz what what are you that
isn't you know going away you know your
body we could put your brain in a jar
you know what I mean it's like or your
identity your name all of these things
you could completely just fall away and
then it would I don't I don't know
everything would kind of be the same I I
I don't know what would be the same so
like it's now it's a post-apocalyptic
future and you and I are like cavemen
we're [__] everywhere we're
constantly playing with ourselves and
and we like I am a non- murderer well
now you put me in a situation where
there's a biker gang that's trying to
eat my legs I you know I just murdered
nine guys and there's no legal because I
had to yeah you see what I'm saying like
I think this why we're interested in
pushing but when you see how transient
it is I understand why spirit is going
like what do you and every person that's
ever lived and everything that's ever
lived have in common and we could call
that Soul or whatever you want to say
but like what is it so I think it's
interesting that you're trying to kind
of have a yard sale of your oh how do
you mean of your La of your labels like
you got rid of your nicotine you got rid
of yeah I mean and it's all kind of like
free flowing I mean like I go in and out
of a lot of different things I like I
like I like try certain things I'll I'll
try a thing to like bring me towards One
Direction a little bit more you know to
try to have an experience to like I just
sort of I'll sort of go with it I mean
like I had a a like a mushroom trip
recently that I was like kind of trying
to like go for that type of like just to
sort of reset a little bit I kind of
went for it and it was that was your
intention that was my intention was to
just like to get back to the bottom line
yeah what's the bottom line here all
this there's this noise what's the
bottom line which by the way is why Adam
and Eve are naked you know what I mean
it's like it's not what's the it's
what's the bottom line to be sexy it's
like can we strip away as much as we can
and what's a metaphor to help us
understand that naked Humanity pure you
know and one with need anything don't
need yeah exactly you have everything so
tell me about this trip the trip was um
it was a lot of just laying down and
just it was just kind of um just feel
just feeling the Simplicity and and
feeling Beyond myself that everything is
okay fine that it's fine relax about it
I got to like kind of ask it questions
for the first time oh wow yeah yeah yeah
little Q&A little Q&A it was a little
bit of like it was just a a place or or
or a feeling or a thing was just I was
sort of engulfed in it whatever that
thing is and I just sort of was in there
and I was like it felt so alien yeah um
but also like like I knew it as well and
then I do you just mean foreign or do
you mean like extraterrestrial
extraterrestrial it felt
extraterrestrial so I asked it I was
like are you like me like are we the
same am I like you am I am I part of you
and it said you were you are in me and
everything is in me like I'm I'm part of
all of it and then I was like okay and
then I um that's it and then I took that
we just turned the cameras off yeah
that's it but the experience so mystical
whatever mystical Islam mystical
whatever is experiential it's just a
fancy word for experiential that's what
I'm trying to get when you experience
dude i' I've had it too where you
experience
like uh I want to get back to that yeah
but the the thing that you made me think
of was like I was like almost every time
I have like a like it could be a drug
induced or any sort of spiritual
experience I'm always like I have to
tell my mom about this yeah and the last
time I had that I was having a really
was on ketamine was having a very very
profound it's all it's all just me and I
don't mean Pete I mean that alien thing
it's all just this one thing yeah and I
was like I got to tell so Then Pete kind
of showed up in the experience and was
like we got to tell Mom about this
because I love my mom and she introduced
me to spirituality and I wanted to have
it and then it was like and this is
going to sound weird but it was like
you're doing it for your mom like your
mom is in this you are you are your mom
well this is kind of the trip I got
caught up in when with it it was I was
with a friend of mine who was raised in
a very similar in certain circumstances
of just being a human we have similar
like his dad is from Lebanon like my dad
is from Lebanon and they immigrated here
and they had kids young and and me and
my friend were the same age we did this
thing together and we kind of got caught
up in this thing of like our dads never
got to do this they they never got to
like experience they wanted to probably
know themselves a little bit more but
they ran out of time and they kept and
this is their way of living on like we
were talking about earlier of like like
wanting your kids to be like you so that
you can live forever they wanted like us
is just like us experiencing whatever it
is getting deeper in ourselves is like
is is doing it for our dads that's it is
we are helping them already that's the
whole thing so I want to do this bit
about like I have this feeling I don't
really believe this but I'm like I have
this feel feeling that when I die the
whole thing ends and the punchline is
like a dream like when I wake up from a
dream everybody goes with me it's over
yeah yeah like I woke up dream's over
and I do believe that in like a
spiritual sense sort of like that's
really what the end of the world is it's
not hinging on me it's just like when
this thing is done pretending to be
separate the whole thing will kind of
lovingly vanish when you pretend when
you're done pretending to be separate
when I mean the big the alien thing you
were talking to when it's like I'm done
pretending to be all of you yeah Malik
I'm not going to be Malik I'm not going
to be Pete I'm just okay poof the
dream's over the whole thing ends that's
the end of the world that's the end
times it's not buildings on fire and
demons flying in the sky that's that's
what Hollywood did with it it's actually
a an Awakening a realization but I'm not
going to say that in the joke in the
joke I just go you know like a dream I
think when I end like I just can't
picture you eating a sandwich and I'm
dead like I just can't like you're just
walking around going like remember Pete
like I can't and then this is the punch
line I go I haven't tried it yet I go
and isn't it frustrating you'll never be
able to tell me I was
wrong like I'm going to die thinking
that was true and you'll never be able
to tell me I was wrong and because you
think it that it is kind of true it is
true for me I but going back to how I
started I don't really believe that I do
think there's something about the
Oneness that you just brought to mind is
you are having those experiencing
experiences for with and as your dad I I
I believe that literally I really have
feeling that lately right is that I'm
kind of playing out um his like
unfinished business a little bit as we
all are as yeah and we're all trying to
carry the ball exactly that's that's
exactly right the whole there's only one
ball in one field and we're just trying
to get it in the end zone and everybody
just keeps kind of pushing it for
forward we keep having these lives and I
think we're trying to work out the noise
of of the one Soul so that we can just
then all merge hopefully agree at some
point and it's all conspiring even the
fact that we don't have to go to the CVS
to develop our film anymore what do we
do with those two hours it it might be
you took mushrooms you know what I'm
saying like I'm saying it's all it it
flatten goes into everything yeah it all
goes and but the whole thing is booby
trapped and rigged even technology Advan
in so my father when I go like why
doesn't my father go like who am I or
whatever well my father was Pro like I
picture my dad's childhood like Dick
Tracy you know he's wearing like a newsy
hat and he's wearing suspenders like
Mickey Mouse and he and he and he's
having to get in fist fights with
everybody for like a tuna sandwich that
he ate that gave him the protein to make
the sperm that made me so he had like a
rougher time I'm 44 and I'm finally
appreciating that my my both of my
parents the hierarchy of needs they had
so many
more uh impending threats to just their
basic day yeah that of course they
weren't going around and and of course
they look down on the hippies that were
smoking a Jay and listening to a Romos
lecture you know what I'm saying like oh
must be nice I'm over here fighting a
pigeon yeah exactly and that was
probably I'm assuming it sounds like a
little bit more like your dad and your
friend's dad yeah they yeah they had to
survive they had to be more of like the
they had to have more of the animalistic
quality of just like of what and and and
and now like because I don't have that I
have a little bit more of like the hours
in the day that weren't spent fighting a
tiger are now spent being uh worried
about something yeah whatever it
whatever it is there's a dread side to
that as well is we were programmed to
run from tigers and there might have
even been an equinity to my father's
more like Scrappy there I'm sure they
probably like I'm sure there was a
little bit more peace than I think think
that they had even even within the fear
the fear probably like uh like melded
into the whole all of him easier than it
it does with me because I I'm seeing all
this other stuff you're worried about a
comment on a you know what I mean yeah
that's not it's looser it's not natural
yeah it's it's it's unnatural yeah I I
remember Richard W wrote about he's a
Franciscan he he talked about like
Shepherds he was like I think the reason
why we see Shepherds in holy literature
or the Bible specifically is that like
yeah quiet people in those times that
had the time to like stand around their
[__] sheep or grazing yeah those are
people that go like wait a minute what
what am I you know what I mean like what
you're looking at the sky you're looking
at sheep you're in a field there's
nothing to do for six hours and then
you're going to bring them back you have
six hours to essentially pray and I
don't mean a list a laundry list of
Demands I mean to get quiet and like
you're doing strip it down and try and
talk to that alien yeah yeah try and
talk to it but it wasn't an alien I
guess it was just uh I think it was you
I think it was me and and it was kind of
it was it was the me in the way that I'm
everything the big me the big me this is
what I'm saying the big me that when the
big me is done that's the end of the
world yes that's what you're saying
about like when yeah if I if I'm if I'm
everything then there's nothing when
it's over kind of thing so when you say
it all depends on me
this is where you kind of have to like
split when you were talking about the
50-50 heart it's like I I do think
there's another this is going to be hard
to explain but we're like we're we're in
it yeah people are watching this YouTube
like inedible I clicked I clicked the
wrong link this is not a chill this is
not a chill conversation but it is going
back to what you say I mean I understand
what you mean going back to what you
said when you say my life might not work
out right Malik's life might not go Gang
Busters I think you're in the one% of
spirituality meaning understandably a
lot of people go I believe in God
because he protects me like the mafia I
pay out to him yeah I don't what do you
need you need you need some Commandments
yeah you want an 11th commandment I I'll
get you another tck up five praise and
we'll see KCK up five praise and I'll
protect you yeah I'll keep you healthy
I'll keep your loved ones healthy and
when do we lose our faith when things go
goofy when they go sideways which by the
way speaking of Christianity I'm like
you realize the spokesperson of this
Faith was murdered brutally murdered and
we've turned it into like if you roll
with Jesus nothing will happen for you
and you pray to a bleeding I'm not
trying to be disrespectful a man who's
bleeding out who's who's uh joining you
in the suffering of the world and you're
saying please help me not suffer is is
pretty
funny his whole way of relating to all
of us is that he's like he's like I am
yeah I can I can suffer yeah and I'm
suffering with you see when I said
you're doing that with through whatever
I said I think when we're suffering God
is suffering as us with us you know what
Ian it's not like God Is Watching You
Suffer you
are in a sense God suffering you're
playing it out you're playing it out
yeah you're you're playing the part in
the play because the whole thing is
figuring something out yeah and I mean
it's I've heard people say that we are
we are God experiencing itself and I'm
sure some some people think that's kind
of a Blasphemous way to think of of it
right um but it does feel like it is in
in some ways that we are just kind of
like I don't know we're just letting the
tape unravel and working out this big
thing so that we can be done with it I
don't know I don't know what to what end
you know what satisfies me cuz I'm with
you mhm I don't Pete is not God I'm with
you it helps me to say I'm a Child of
God meaning you can say things that will
contradict that and be like there's no
line separating my Essence from God but
there is it helps my it helps me and
keeps me humble to say like I'm not the
overse you know I'm not the all all I'm
not the ground of being I am the ground
of being but I'm also not you know what
I mean like let's put a little distance
there's a little bit distance every once
in a while you can like get a little
closer to it and then like see through
that eye a little bit and then be like
okay but I'm still yeah I'm still this
like this matter you know and as long as
we're believing we're separate then
we're not fully cooked you know what I
mean that's okay and this moment was
when I was talking to it felt very much
like I was a child very much cuz that's
that's that's helpful to me I like am I
like you I felt like a little like a bab
I was like am I like like I was like
trying to figure out like you know when
a baby looks at its hand and it's like
what the like that's how I kind of felt
about it and you see your dad's hand and
you're like oh yeah yeah and I asked it
the next question was uh do you love me
just to know I just wanted and he was
like sorry we got to go to the
midrolls uh the perfect je these are the
jeans look how stretchy they are look at
that something I think is funny is we
talk about the secret to success people
are always like what's the secret to
success and we know we know the answer
we know meditation helps we know Fitness
helps we know sleep helps we know breath
work helps but we sort of Need A little
nudge to get these things actually
folded in and integrated into our life
so I'm so happy for this new pet pick
which is the app open which is actually
here to guide you and to help you set
yourself up for success with the things
we already know we should be doing but
making it streamline and easy and easy
to make it a part of your daily routine
starting your day with open ending your
day with open what does that mean
exactly well you do the breath work in
the morning it makes me feel focused
more than coffee it's incredible then
you can pop over to their Fitness to
build strength and mobility and get this
this is the coolest one I've been using
the meditation part before for bed and
I'm asleep in under 10 minutes that
alone if this was just a sleep app it
would be enough that gets you asleep in
10 minutes but it does so much more than
that it helps you and motivates you
towards your fitness goals helps you and
motivates you towards your meditation
goals it is basically mindfulness
digitized Health Fitness breath sleep
all in one place my only regret is not
starting using open sooner this app will
change your life and if you want to get
on my daily routine you can get 30 days
free of open by visiting with open.com
weird again that's 30 days free by
visiting with
open.com weird oh and if you're in La
make sure to check out their new studio
to practice with open in person which of
course is super super cool we talk a lot
about mindfulness on this on this pod we
talk a lot about breath work on this pod
talk a lot about meditation on this pod
and of of course we're talking about
sleep and improving our life and getting
moving open is the all-in-one place to
implement these things into your life
support this show support your own
well-being go to with
open.com weird you can get 30 days free
so cool check it out all right back to
Malik okay you said do you love me do
you love me and um the the energy was a
little bit of like come on that that's
that's the Divine voice to me come on
man yeah come on come on what are we
doing yeah yeah yeah because the
question it was like it was like of like
a like a kid who's tired after a long
day of play of just being on the earth
of just like running around like am I
okay and then it was just like a hand
and it was like you're fine don't worry
about it the the the parent child thing
again Richard roar I quote this all the
time but he's like our
efforting to know and understand God is
sort of darling to God that's how it
felt you know what I mean it's not it's
like you poor thing so wrapped up in the
world was like asking in the ocean would
you would you even get me wet and it's
like I'm wetness I'm wetness you're
soaked
yeah what are you talking about you're
soaked you're you're actually sugar and
you got dissolved into it and you're
going like but is it and I get it look
keep even me yes yeah take away my
coffee and my whatever my needs are can
I get narrow vision and go like we're
just a chicken bone in the gutter for
sure so I understand asking yeah and I
don't think it ever tires of of saying
like yeah it's okay you always have to
ask yeah we're always asking we're
asking all the time with everything we
do I think a little bit I agree I
completely agree so he said do you let
me in and goes come
on doing come on he goes
come on kind of [__] question is that
what kind you you want me to protect you
can I tell you one just that you just
cuz you might enjoy it yeah James Finley
wrote I believe in a God who protects me
from nothing but sustains me in
everything isn't that great protects me
from nothing and sustains me in
everything well think about the like I I
always go to my divorce yeah I was not
protected from that and that was a big
blow to my faith I I married the first
girl I had sex with I was like I'm doing
everything right she has an affair she
runs away she runs away cuzz I'm I'm the
place and she runs away from her
perspective she's like I got the hell
out of there so depends on who the
narrator is but in my 28-year-old mind I
was like H she ran away right um but in
that pain I there was a
sustaining presence even when I was like
at my lowest and really just dark there
was still something when you looked for
the bare naked Adam and Eve
being core it was still there it was
still there so what I'm saying what I
love about that is you're saying even if
if Malik's life doesn't go perfectly
that doesn't change Ultimate Reality
that's very mushroom to me yeah to go
like the reality of the ground of being
is not contingent on my mood or even my
life totally rocking yeah that's that's
ego that's ego that's ego to get that it
is yeah God help me find a parking spot
and then he doesn't and you're like well
this God's not paying God's having an
off day I'm going to look up Zeus I'm
going to learn some Greek prayers and
see if he does all is sleeping yeah yeah
let's mix it up who's it's like uh I I
give to a charity called um give well
give well.org and they they find the
Charities that are underserved cuz there
are sexy Charities that get like all the
attention and they're like money yeah
but nobody wants to help these people
that like really need it so you give it
to them and they have an algorithm that
that funnels it I give well.org it's
great mhm similarly can we find the gods
that are not getting bothered as much
everyone's going to J
JC you know what I mean Allah's huge can
we find Hermes is anyone bugging Hermes
days he bored dude he's yeah he's fast
yeah he's flicking a lightning bolt like
a like a nickel he's just sitting there
and you go Hermes can you find yes yes
yes did he just eat it yeah he ate the
lightning bolt and he's he's charged up
he's ready to go you got to find the
gods that have the time yeah yeah don't
be the 100 millionth caller be the first
caller to whme Hermes class rigid don't
be so rigid it's not all it's not all
just it's not all uh a and and Jesus and
it's all whatever you have the you have
the HSPA to go to Yahweh get the [__]
you got you got
you got to have faith it's all it's all
what was the middle word Ean what's Eman
mean faith in Arabic you know it's all
just the different versions of it yeah
man okay we we've met our riff quota we
can still call ourselves a comedy
podcast back to everything being one no
you so what else did you say to the to
the alien
um I didn't I I I kind of left it at
that I kind of opened my eyes and I like
Ian what else is there I yeah there was
nothing left to ask it yeah he said I
was like do you love me he said any more
stupid [__] questions any this
[__] kid you you love me and then no
I didn't I didn't ask anything else I
kind of got up and then just sat up and
was like were you alone no I was with my
friend okay I was with my friend and um
and it was beautiful and then you know
and then I went on to like go and try to
like implement it but uh it was so
fleeting and it and it uh it was really
sad to like see it go and to see the and
to know to know that it was that simple
and to know that I knew how simple
everything was and then to and then to
still get caught up in the world like to
get upset at my dad it's not for the
faint of heart this finding these big
things because then you have to face the
humbling that you like I tasted it I am
my mother I am my father it's all this
thing and then you're like Dad you know
like exactly what happened I went back
home and then my dad I was just a little
I had a little not enough sleep and then
my dad was like trying to he was trying
to like have a good time with me he was
trying to joke with me and I was like I
can't I was like I can't and I was like
what the you just you always can I just
had this experience of that I always can
and it was just kind of like uh showed
me that it's like it's never you never
just get there and you snap and then
you're there it's always work and it's
always you're you never um you never
arrive you're always going I think right
I think that's true and I think you know
the eart toes of the world seem to
say you're going to get angry you're
going to have these feelings right so um
p p ped trodan says um you're the sky
that's was your experience the rest is
just weather right isn't that beautiful
so I think the key is yeah that's heads
space stuff it
is not a sponsor please believe that I'm
just kidding um but
like when you realize fully you're died
in the wool you know you're this Sky I
think the weather keeps coming you just
don't um you don't identify with it I
think is the way that they might say it
it's like the frustration comes and you
go like oh there's frustration and you
allow it you know like rain recognize
allow recognize allow investigate
nurture I think I'm getting that right
so when I have those feelings and Val
this is where my wife my wife Val is
such a good counterbalance I love
getting hey and being like it's all one
it's we know this like we're being kind
of masculine in this like we know this
we should know yeah and she's so such a
perfect harmony to this that just goes
like yeah and Malik's going to get upset
at his Dad or not want to play around or
whatever it is and that's okay and that
being part of it rather than me being in
opposition to information of the Oneness
buddy that I that I'm like some that
that I'm somehow pushing away the
Oneness of the World by being upset with
my dad and it's like no that's actually
the the greatest example of it yeah is
that even in that and talking about
everything co-c conspiring to move
things forward I'm never more so Leonard
Cohen says the cracks are how the light
gets through right so you have the you
you bump up against your dad and you
crack but then like these things seep in
more deeply because of the wounding
right so I just just this past weekend I
had like a little dust up with my dad
and I just noticed
like when I was like scared and angry
and every all these things I was just so
much more porous to everyone to everyone
else's needs yeah like when everything's
rocking this is why like as much as I
love uh Andrew huberman and Tony Robin
and these people that are just like get
up in the morning and go like this go
like this for 35 seconds what mean all
the air in the world and you're fine and
they're just figuring it out yeah elbow
elbow a mirror nine times and this is
going to trick your brain into thinking
that you are the fastest man know yeah
yeah yeah I love that stuff yeah and
it's incomplete unless we're sharing our
Brokenness it's just not the full thing
it's
like and I'm sure those people can and
do but you see what I'm saying like Pete
who's just going around killing it
[__] biking around an apple orchard
isn't really that much use to you I
wouldn't do standup yeah you know what I
mean I wouldn't do this podcast like if
I was just like [__] figured it out
that Brokenness I experienced with my
father is in and we we sewed it up but
like is informing and helping this
conversation because I need you to see
me and and you need me to see you
because of these vulnerabilities so it's
not a flaw in the system it's just so
hard to remember the cracks make it so
that you want to
connect you want to seal the cracks with
everybody else that's right with the
with the rest of the world you have like
who you are and then there's you can
fill it in I think that's with standup
what I'm trying to I guess with just
what I'm I'm I think I just want to
connect and I think that's like stand up
is like a way that I like connecting and
I think that's maybe what I was going
for when I was younger it was like just
a connection in some way absolutely I
like I don't know how um I don't know
how to get it through this thing I don't
know how to pray so I'm like let me just
try and find it and then now I'm trying
to find it yeah how to connect remember
when we were in Vancouver you murdered
in front of a thousand people those
people became like one with the ideas in
the room and and they get the piece of
that oh let me take a break from my own
mind and we'll all have this one mind
that's the you know the responsibility
and the fun of being a comedian like
let's all think this yeah it's very it's
very powerful same with a movie yeah
it's let's all have the same dream
instead of all these lonely isolated
private dreams we have at night let all
have the same dream together and talk
about it let's try as hard as we can to
be one for a second I think that's all
of it yeah I I'm not a huge fan of live
music but I understand it's like let's
all hear hear this song now yeah I'm
like my brain goes like just listen to
the record but like when you're in a
when you're in a room with all those
people and you and you see them all
listening to it and it's a song you know
and you realize that everybody has their
own feelings about this song yeah and
that everybody's had happy and sad
moments to the song you're like yeah
there's like a it's not the same as what
we do but you're carrying it together
yeah yeah it's not the same as what we
do but it's not the same as um as how
maybe we experience it but it's all it's
just it's a it's like a conduit for us
to have an experience through we have
these we do these things that are just a
way for people to like pour themselves
into for a second totally yeah and
vanish a little bit yeah and also stand
out it's it's a it's a paradox I'm
looking at your shirt I'm remember you
worked with special needs kids I'm
wondering if that had any effect on you
and your perspective of the world I
think so I think maybe yeah I think I
just I think I just wanted to to help I
wanted to just get I just wanted to be
in something a lot a lot of the time
like belong and and participate and
contribute yeah I think I just kept I
kept looking for that this was um my
friend John who I met doing theater who
was like my one of my favorite people
ever who like I met through that and we
just became like best friends and he has
um a brother with Down syndrome and uh I
remember I remember growing up and
watching a a movie that was about a
special needs boy with shy La buff I
remember and it was nobody knows about
this movie but I remember seeing him
doing this and I'm feeling just so so
bad for him in the movie like he was
getting bullied and I just was like I
think as a child I was like this is not
I was like there's got to be something
we could do about this I'm with you
there's a certain it broke my heart as a
kid that because I just didn't get it
like I didn't didn't know anybody's
special needs when I was a kid but I
just so this was like my introduction to
that there was people who were
experiencing things differently and then
there were kids like being like mean to
them and it like broke my heart and then
I just kind of I think I like looked in
I like looked in the newspaper to try to
see them like is there a way to like how
do you get inv movie and you looked in
the newspaper to get involved yeah I'm
yeah I'm like the last par should be PR
if your if your parents listen to this
two things one what a gorgeous heart you
have and two if you were a stock
like if there was a comedy stock like
exchange I'd invest so much money in you
because I have no doubt you're going to
do fantastic so what are your parents
names uh elham elham and Muhammad and
Muhammad yeah do not worry your son is
going to be just fine yeah they'll never
listen to this okay well in that case e
I'm just kidding they're the best I
didn't know if they if they were those
types of folks um they uh yeah and I
remember yeah I just I met uh John and I
just kind of we I would just hang out
with him and his family at his house and
I would hang out with his brother and
then he just uh his Down syndrome his
brother with Down syndrome and uh yeah
you shouldn't say Down syndrome brother
but the brother with he can honestly and
also and here's the thing this is what I
learned through this family is that
they're saying all of it there's they're
not like there's no thing that don't say
that the people who have those rules AR
typically the parent yeah no uh one of
Leela's best friends has Down syndrome
and we're very close with the family and
she's like she's like family to us all
of them and uh that was the first thing
we noticed the
uptightness isn't coming from them per
se I'm sure there are some
uncomfortableness of people who don't
who don't have those people in their
lives I think who don't know how to talk
about it right and yeah so yeah and then
he he just was like maybe you could he
worked at this place and then he was
like you should come and what inter for
it it's really my job was called social
experience guide and I was 19 so I
didn't have any social experience but
they were like you can maybe just try
and just kind of just be a chill just be
a chill guy around these guys play play
games with them go swimming with them go
to the movies it was just that like that
was that was my job wow and it was uh it
was the best there was thing called
movie project that was very fun a lot of
these guys they just like make movies my
friend Christian um started a thing
called the movie project and then like
they they just make the their their
films and they learn how to make movies
and there's a lot of programs editing
and and coming up stop motion all kinds
of things yeah it's a it's a beautiful a
beautiful place wow and how long did you
do it I worked there on and off for like
uh three years I think yeah what what
did you and it's okay if you don't have
an answer this isn't Super Soul Sunday
but like if you learn something or
another way to look at that is what do
people get wrong wrong about people with
special needs what did you figure out
oh the thing that I figured out and I'll
and I'll say and this is and and I got
fired for this at
first but I'm dying to know what you're
about to say I figured something out and
this is actually why I was fired but
history made me a Victor in this cuz I
was fired and then rehired okay can't
wait but I used
to I would do impressions of them to to
them and did they I would make fun of
they loved it yeah I would do
impressions of their voice and then
things they would do and not in a
disrespectful way but in a way of like
inclusion of like d i do Impressions I
make fun of people who I love yeah and
so I would make fun of them I
immediately understand what you're what
you're talking about there's there's an
othering and a white glove sensitivity
that you in your time with them started
to notice wasn't coming from them
meaning yeah they didn't want it at all
they wanted to be involved they wanted
to fold it in they wanted to bump mics
they wanted wanted to yeah they wanted
to get roasted or whatever not even
roasted it was just they wanted to just
be in it and then I remember there were
some people who were like that's not we
don't do that here and I was like all
right and then I was like oh and then I
remember I came back and wait did they
say we don't do that there and then you
kept doing it and then you were let go
or they just no I was fired and then
that was like a a reason why I was that
was part of the reason and then that
person who fired was fired and then I
was brought back wow why were they fired
they were doing your
bits they were they didn't have the
sauce I had kills they weren't good at
The
Impressions yeah oh my God yeah to see a
scene in a movie where a guy tries to do
that and he's not funny though and the
kids are like what are you doing Malik
right now yeah yeah are you doing M with
Down Syndrome trying to trying to be him
it's not working no yeah yeah and then
they brought you back they brought me
back and then did that sort of levity
frivolity continue did you I kind of
yeah I think I tried to you know I tried
to just be light with it I I think it
was just that it was it was not don't
not everything is so serious even when
things are very like drastic and people
need meds and people need people need
more taken care of it's like it's a
little bit more a person yeah treat
everybody that yeah yeah it was that
there's no like okay there's no like I
didn't do any of that they really didn't
want you to do that tiring yeah
everybody does that to them if everybody
treats you the same way it must get just
like any human person it's like this is
really really boring yeah and I have to
imagine that a a friend that could would
be more interested in seeing you as a
person and and finding out what makes
you laugh yeah yeah I I again like
everything we've talked about I
definitely see both sides if I just
walked in and saw you doing it I'd be
like I think we have to hit this guy
with a fire extinguisher like I don't
think this we need to get this guy being
like I don't want to drink water yeah
exactly I don't know if that's but you
know it's so funny that's the other ring
that can be so I understand sensitivity
but what like intense automatic meaning
not individually discerned but just like
an automatic you know sensitiv like
hyper sensitivity uh can steam clean a
lot of intimacy and laughter yeah you
can't go that deep yeah with with a
person or just like you can't have as
much experience nothing makes me laugh
harder than uh people making fun of me
and and God help you if you do an
impression of me to me I don't know if
that means I have narcissistic
personality disorder but like I want to
be like taken out by somebody that I
love and they do James Adomian does it
to me and I just die yeah that was kind
of it they and they loved it that was
that was the one thing that I that's
what you figured out that's what I
figured out there make fun of do
Impressions with people well it's
interesting I'm thinking about Paul
Mercurio he did warm up for the Daily
Show and I occasionally would fill in
for him so I would watch him do it and I
remember if there was somebody in a
wheelchair or something yeah he's doing
all crowd work he would immediately kind
of do and and you know it's a risk he
would make jokes to the person he talk
to the person whatever it was I'm not
even in this day and age I'm just saying
like yes and he I always remember it
they were loving it having a great time
and then and that's always a risk cuz
people pretend to have a great time I
hear I can see the other side yeah to so
that everybody else doesn't feel bad
don't feel bad I love this and then they
go home I I've been that person too y
but he did say something that I always
remember uh that he like he put his hand
on them and and was like see everybody
here CU they weren't laughing he's like
they want me to treat you as as another
another but I'm going to treat you like
I'm treating everybody and then he went
and made fun of every single person in
the crowd so I mean it has to be kind of
like a it reminds me of the Key and
Peele sketch the guy with the trick do
the voice do something about the voice
yeah and and the guy was like talk about
the burns yeah talk about the burns yeah
I mean I've had it a couple of times
when I'm on stage where there's somebody
like heckling a whole show but I can
just tell the way that they're heckling
I was like I know this type of heckling
and I've stopped the show a couple times
and then I've I've kind of been like
I've said do you have autism and and
everybody in the I've had people in the
crowd go like who and I'm like no no no
not in a like a do you have autism I'm
like are you on the Spectrum and they go
yeah I'm on the Spectrum okay so I'm
like this is how you're you're having a
good time then the way that this is how
you're having a good time so you're
you're trying you're engaging with the
show because that you're feeling a
little bit of this is what you think it
is the pressure of the of the social
environment and they were like yeah and
then I was like I gave a little bit of
space for that and but but I felt the
need at first to be like tell this guy
to shut the [__] up yeah and but I but
then I was like let me make it just a
little just stop it for a second to be
like do
you do you see the world differently
than everybody else right now yeah and
then he did and then we kind of like we
like hashed it out and was like I like
asked like what his um not ticks what
are the words for it like uh what his
what his needs were kind of to enjoy the
show I was like what do you need to
enjoy the show and uh kind of whoa get
and I I kind of gave it to him for a
second and then it was uh
whoow and I don't even know what I'm I'm
I'm I'm saying with that exactly but
that was kind of no that's part where
they both met you're seeing a need I'll
relate to that story is I'll never
forget I was at the Boston comedy club
in New York and some guy was heckling
and look I understand this is a little
virtue signal or whatever it's called
bigging yourself up but I just said to
the guy everybody was telling him to
shut the [__] up and all that stuff it's
funny because there were like eight
people there and one of them's heckling
and I was just like what what's going on
this is back when my comedy Persona
wouldn't even allow for me to say shut
up yeah I'm just kind of talking about
big league cheu and stuff so I had my
only recourse and something I'd still do
to this day I'd like to think is I said
what's up like what's going on similar
to you with the Au and and he was just
like I I couldn't remember if he just
got divorced or if he lost his job but
something had happened that day and this
sad bag of bones went to a comedy show
yeah and the show sucked and he was he
wasn't going to lose twice no he I'm I'm
funny something you guys I can't do this
I need this today please no and this is
all out loud of course I need this yeah
no no you go up are you on the Spectrum
no just rough day bad day bad day you
remember what happened to
him I it was one of those two yeah I
think it might have been job uh-huh and
he was fine the rest of the show but
that that little bit of like what do you
need sometimes you need and could the
neediest person in the room meaning the
comedian begrudge another person well we
do I mean I do I hate when people talk
talk and [__] up the show well yeah um
but like I don't know and not to Big up
standup so much as if it's so important
I I do I think it's very important but I
don't want to make it out that it is the
most important thing but there is a lot
of need involved and people people show
up with with a lot of stuff going on
show up with a lot of
expectation you ever had somebody come
up to you after a show and be like I
needed that oh yeah and you're like oh
that's my opener yeah I open now going I
need this does anyone else need this and
people cheer and I'm like I like
remembering that my little traumas big
traumas old traumas just humiliations
embarrassments let's work them all out
uhhuh and I'm it's really me trying to
remember they are coming hoping that the
the hard pressure of laughter will will
like brush off some dirt you know yeah
yeah so I'm agree mhm did I ruin it no
we're allowed to have a LOL we're
allowed to be quiet for a second don't
let the ferociousness of modernity can
we say l Akbar is that the lull is
great lbar yeah the lull is great lull
is greater than the talking sometimes
oh my God yeah if we learn nothing from
the
mushrooms um so oh when did you get into
drugs um when you were in theater I
started smoking weed with kids oh this
is just weed it was yeah yeah yeah CU in
your stand up you say I say drugs
because it's like I'm because it's what
am I going to say you know I don't know
I thought you said hard drugs no I said
I would rather do hard drugs than pork
for some reason I was like does m like
have some sorted pth like no I would
drinking I think I would drink and and I
I mean I'll still smoke weed sometimes
but it was like I just kind of I think I
was just
exercising the bit pork a little bit a
little bit but then but that was the one
that I stopped before everything I'm
like this is what am I doing yeah like
go this is ridiculous yeah yeah yeah if
I'm doing this then how do I even I
don't eat pork and
I what I was in a restaurant with Phil
Rosenthal name name droppy so he took me
to this incredible Chinese restaurant in
Canada I believe I might have been in
Vancouver it might have been were
talking about yeah I seen Phil Rosen
that day he had done the show before us
yeah this was the same day he sat in the
green room with us I remember you
talking about this and I ate he was like
there's a little pork in this and it was
like a crispy fried rice I can't even
describe it they don't have it at PF
chanks let's just say that this is like
real [__] cuz Vancouver's got like a
really legit uh Chinese population so
I'm eating this stuff he's like the chef
like when the chef dies this recipe goes
like he's like there's no it's gone like
and he grows certain fruits and things
and spices in his yard and he brings it
so like the rare and I was like okay I'm
going to eat a little Pork yeah and I
put this thing in my mouth and I was
like I put this thing in my mouth I put
this rice dish in my mouth and I
literally like got emotional at how
delicious it was wow but I still you
know yeah I cheated and it was nice
that's that's the the cheating or the
not of it like I'm that's the thing
about the rigidness is even now even now
in this like I don't drink I don't I do
these I do these things that I'm
supposed to not do or I don't do these
things I'm supposed to not do and I'm
wondering like what how how much are
those my rules I don't know even I'm
like I wonder what situation comes up
and how much I'm denying the present to
not do something or to do it I mean like
even with me like quitting smoking a
little bit of I'm always like well what
when what comes up that I will you know
what I mean that you will smoke that I
will or that I that yeah something comes
I don't know because I don't want to
yeah deny the world sometimes I don't
know like the thing I don't know
I I was just going to apologize for
always mentioning the New Testament but
I just know it please I'm I'm up to my
eyeballs in Quran all the time please
tell me about the Bible for for Christ
sake I mean didn't Muhammad say Christ
was a great prophet he loves him he
loves him he's he's uh he's his Prophet
there you go he's his messenger buddy
yeah these are the these are the big
three the big five Big Five Big Five
what are the other two there's Muhammad
Isa oh I meant the religions I meant uh
Judaism Christianity and Islam oh
there's five Messengers five Messengers
all right I've not every day I'm out
religious but I loved it 25 prophets
five Messengers okay
yeah hardcore not bad Jesus would say uh
you know he's he's basically just
wandering around with 12 dudes and they
would pick Grain on the Sab ab and
people were always asking him like if a
goat falls in a hole on the Sabbath can
you get it out you know Jewish
legalistic questions yeah and Jesus was
always like you know there's that line I
think about it all the time as I ate
that pork it's not what goes in a man's
mouth that makes him Pure or unpure it's
what comes out of his mouth that sort of
stuff yeah and I was like Jesus was
pretty look I I can't say I have it
figured out I'm just saying there's a
lot of verses that are like will you
stop it's like it's like your mushroom
thing will you stop will you stop with
all the rules the rules are just to get
here exactly you're already there maybe
the rules aren't the the thing that's
right the rules are Paving the way to
the thing and once you're at the thing
you could uh I say this all the time but
Raman Mahari says like the the the
tradition is the stick that you stoke
the fire with the fire is your Awakening
well once the fire is big enough you
even throw the stick in and I was like
oh my God I like that [__] dope yeah
yeah yeah all these yeah all the the the
the no pork the don't drink is just to
get to the the place get to the place
and like sometimes I'm like well if the
place is I don't know I don't know how
much I don't know how much my rules are
my rules yet even no and you shouldn't
you're you're wiser than your years for
sure but I I still don't know what's
obviously I don't know what's going on
but like it's it's nice to see you on
this path it's awesome thank you I mean
I I was thinking about coming on this
podcast cuz I don't I started the I
learned about comedy listening to this
podcast you did this is how I know about
comedy at all is listening to you oh my
god oh because you're over there going
like can someone explain this to me and
then podcast truly yeah I was over there
and I was like working at Walmart and I
used to go to Gold's Gym across the
street and I would listen to you
interview people and I would learn about
who was who and what was what bits and
yeah and and uh and meeting K the other
night was like I was like like and now
being here was like very um it feels
very like surreal but also but this is
how I like got remind me where I started
off on this point oh man uh the
podcaster how I was saying like I think
you were saying like being on the show
matters to you because you learned about
comedy through this oh goodness but we
were talking about pork and it gets you
to the place oh no this is ridiculous
the rules oh I had such a good point not
drinking not eating pork or get you to
the place oh once you're in the
place and then you were
saying God how did you say the lull is
greater Allah abbar whatever allahar I
can't remember but uh it'll come back um
but but that's how you filled in those
blanks and those gaps learning what what
comedy was yes I can't remember there
was something I really wanted to tell
that's what you're like but I don't know
where that was going I just like knowing
that that's the case yeah that's really
cool yeah I'll uh it'll come back to me
it'll come back to me it's okay you ever
see a
ghost
oo
uh I saw one time I think I don't know
it could have been ey floaters but I I
uh I saw these things in the field that
looked like Pac-Man ghosts and I was
like all right I don't I don't think
ghosts actually look like
that it's eating dots yeah these ghost
are eating DTS uh have you ever almost
died um
I've had experiences like the one that I
told you about um which one with just
kind of like melding into something and
not not exactly Vanishing I've had I've
been on a hike and then I've had um a
rock fly past my head that's a good one
and uh and just look up and then like
have like a bunch of like other hikers
be like whoa oh God and then but it it
just missed me and I would have been
like oh yeah if that if that connected I
would have uh but not
anything not anything real would you
rather that or the long drawn out
hospital bed or or you know hospice bed
I think I'm a hospice bed guy I want to
like have a a good death and you know
kind of like Fade Out or sometimes you
think about the the quality of the the
the rock during the hike where you're
just like pink yeah that'd be sometimes
I'd like the James Dean out you know
just kind of go speeding up into a turn
to avoid a semi and you're just yeah
yeah something like that yeah look
either way hey I'll take it either way
I'll
take I'll take whatever you got can you
tell me about the time you laughed
really really really really hard in your
life maybe the hardest you've ever left
yeah I um well I've laugh so much I got
to laugh I've gotten to laugh a lot so
far in my life I feel like the people I
know are the funniest and I'm very lucky
to it's the best part of being a
comunian it's amazing yeah I'll be in a
diner so many times and I be like nobody
laughs like like this is not like how
people live their lives I completely
agree it amazing but we are kind of I
was talking to a friend about this where
I was like of all the things you can
obsess about like you know chewing gum
or basketball picking laughter is the
human phenomenon that you're like we're
only going to talk and think about this
yeah and then you get so obsessed about
it and then it kind of permeates your
Diner life and now you're just laughing
really hard it's one of the fringe
benefits for sure it's amazing yeah I've
had um I've had times with uh with John
my friend John who got me this job and
uh just you know those like you know
when you do a bit that like somehow like
tears apart the whole world then puts it
back together but you put it back
together in the way that you
decide you know what I mean we uh yeah
we've just been sitting there and I
don't know we had we've had these just
had characters over the years we have
this one character named Mo who's just
like a Lebanese guy disgruntled Lebanese
guy who goes into a Sharma shop and asks
him to put everything on
it and this gives you the giggles this
gives us the giggles we just kind of
would talk about this guy going in there
and asking for um for every every little
bit of every single ingredient in the
sandwich and then the guy behind the
counter not even knowing what to do with
all of it and he's he's just telling him
put Lots buddy lot yeah Tomatoes lots
lots lots of everything until the point
where it's it's kind of filled up the
whole
room and some that this made sense to us
in this uh in this situation yeah where
just like this guy is asking for
everything on the sandwich like he wants
like this is how he's talking about the
world like the guy behind the counter is
like I don't know what you're talking
about he's like no buddy keep putting it
keep that is the universe he's just keep
yeah there's a cosmic joke to this now
put a bicycle on it yeah exactly put
yourself in the sandwich yeah the last
step is you get in the sandwich you get
in the sandwich and then and and there's
no way to wrap it up wrap it up from
inside and then you fold the whole
did you see the movie uh connected to
New York I'm halfway through it right
now so you're only what do you mean I'm
halfway through it oh my God Phil
Hoffman I'm halfway through it that's so
sad wait are you watching it currently
yeah what are the [__] chances of
that yeah I'm halfway through he's built
up the whole world he's basically
putting Lots in the play he's put
everything into the sandwich of this
play that's the sandwich yeah yeah yeah
that play it's not a spoiler you'll
still enjoy it but it's very sad and
it's very long and it's hard to get
through but it's great uh but it he
wants to make a play that's everywhere
and that's how it ends is and the last
step is I I won't ruin it but I mean
like it's it's it's what you're talking
about it's folding everything in yeah
it's everything in the sandwich and uh
there was a time me and John we're like
just sitting across from each other and
we we we we somehow got it that we're
like we're putting everything into the
sandwich and it it it made me like laugh
so hard that I almost felt like I
flipped inside out oh my God you know
yes wow that's really beautiful what a
great answer it reminded me my friend ER
and I grew up he had he dated a a South
American girl and her father was
incredibly strict so we always used to
do an impression of him going if you
touch her I will kill you but then that
became we' go transversely if you kill
her I will touch
you
he's kind of like hitting on him he's
like if you kill her I will touch you
and it's like we wow we had like math
jokes like the transitive proper I don't
know what it is but it was something it
completely we flipped
it transversely transversely if you kill
her I will touch
you yeah fantastic I uh I wanted to just
go back and say I don't remember what I
was trying to say but I think what I was
in me explaining all of where I kind of
how I got to where I'm at through
through everything and got into
entertainment everything you were just
kind of and I've talked about being kind
of held along I I learned a lot from
from from you and from your and it kind
of it helped me kind of expand yeah
where I was going and and trying to
learn about these things and I and I uh
I really appreciate that that's that's
what I was trying to say you're very
welcome man I couldn't believe in you
more I think you're so funny he did
Largo it's me and kumel and [__]
whoever and you had the best set of the
night it was incredible well Peter Kim
now the whatever sounds like I'm putting
down Peter Kim Peter Kim was also great
I'm just saying like you murdered and I
was just like I don't know it just feels
very inevitable to me that you're going
to do whatever you want to do and I know
you want to act and do serious stuff but
not but I also think your standup is
going to be huge and I really sincerely
think this is going to be one of those
episodes
like Pete Davidson did the show when he
was like I don't know 20 I know and it
was like Yeah remember and it was like
at that point believe it or not it was
sort of like not that I was doing Pete
Davids in a favor but a little bit like
here's a upand cominging comic I'll have
him on the show and that I think this is
going to be one of those episodes no
[__] oh [__] so thanks man well I'm
going to try to imagine my 18-year-old
self listing to it when it comes out see
what that gold gy yeah yeah you're like
at the Gold's Gym at 2: in the morning
being like am I a Psycho a am I a
psychopath hitting a body bag listening
to you interview Hari cond
deolo putting on boxing gloves to be
like I don't think this is what other
people are listening to in their
headphones right now oh my God I love
when obsession goes right you know what
I mean yeah the same level of obsession
pointed in a different direction and
you're just a a crazy person yeah it
could have very usually happened but we
live in a culture that values the guy
yeah who listened to haric kondabolu at
2 in the morning while you worked out
yeah and I'm so glad do you feel good I
feel good I feel good man all right that
was lovely it was incredible thank you
would you say we've had people say keep
it crispy in in Arabic before and
there's no I've tried to yeah there's no
I don't yeah you say like keep it
crunchy or fried or something it's not
quite the same it's not the same let's
not do it would you just give us a reg
regular what is that West westro Centric
like americ
Amer eurocentric English is regular
let's just do an English uh keep it
crispy to get us out of here okay keep
it
crispy we will Allah abbar God is
greater that was awesome man oh my God
man awesome
wow you made it win oh yeah you made it
win you made it
you made it oh yeah you made it you made
it you made it with oh yeah you made it
you made it you made it with
all